[Music]
I am Stuart brand from long now all of
the great roads in history probably have
a long now story little context the
grave roads of Empire the Roman roads
were several hundred thousand miles of
roads in Italy and Europe fifty thousand
miles were paved when you get the Inka
roads going the entire west coast of
South America twenty four thousand miles
a lot of it through insane mountains
just a couple miles east of here the
Spanish Empire had the El Camino Real
connecting the 21 missions here in
California six hundred miles the
American Empire started to build you got
the nest Natchez Trace which went from
the eastern states down to the Lower
Mississippi four hundred and forty miles
you had the Santa Fe Trail going 900
miles from the Missouri River down to
Santa Fe and then you have some of the
sacred pilgrimage paths which are really
interesting the El Camino de Santiago
which goes from France to far
northwestern Spain is 500 miles Kevin
Kelley you're walking part of that this
summer several hundred thousand people
are doing that one now every year I'd
like to see us I don't have a pilgrimage
path from the clock were installing and
West Texas to our clock site and Eastern
Nevada that would be a thousand miles
across America's empty quarter which
looks a lot like what you just saw in
the long short and nobody goes there but
the most important of all of the roads
went between Empires and it was
consequential for at least 2,000 years
and that's the Silk Road which went
4,700 miles from
to Europe in Europe to China the expert
on that is our speaker Michael Fischetti
[Music]
welcome first of all I want to say thank
you to super brand all the organizers
and members and founders of the long now
what an exciting community of people to
be able to both join in with and think
with about our civilization over an
extended period of time
I'm an archaeologist and so for me the
concept of long-term thinking is
inherent in everything I possibly do
right the notion that folks who don't
dig things out of the ground are
actually paying attention to 10,000
years of human existence is both
encouraging because you know not there's
nothing many jobs out there for
archaeologists um so you know anybody
who has a multibillion-dollar company
and you need an archaeologist on staff
please let me know no I'm actually still
gay I actually I'm game what I want to
do tonight is from the lens of an
archaeologist someone who actually digs
things out of the ground and who tries
to interpret those things with that long
chronological lens I want to talk to you
about this concept of civilization that
we use so colloquial colloquially and
yet we don't be very rarely critique in
the sense of what it actually means most
archeologists even shy away from the
term because it's loaded with lots of
ideas that maybe would seem outdated or
something but in our common parlance
it's definitely part of our everyday
life we think about it when we think
when we consider very very contemporary
issues like war and progress and
development and whether we're going to
send money to help a community that's
been ravaged by a hurricane so I'm going
to take you on a journey today
effectively across the Silk Roads and my
point tonight
be to kind of illustrate that
civilization isn't necessarily what you
think it is and hopefully give you some
real science underneath why I think it
might be something else and then we'll
font we'll end up with a sort of
provocative proposition about maybe
where we should go in the future
because as we know this is really what
the long now is about so my title I'm
not blind to the idea that I'm in
Silicon Valley or at least in the Bay
Area and yet the same the notion of an
open-source civilization a civilization
that isn't bounded but is in fact a wiki
civilization a civilization in which
input is flexible boundaries are open
this is the idea that I want to start
with and I want to juxtapose that in a
sense to this model of civilization this
is an image I took from an airplane
window in 2016 as I was flying into
autumn chi China this is the westernmost
province of China she's young the new
lands and uh what I mean I hope it's
evident here this isn't the city center
this is the city periphery this is the
growth of Chinese civilization today in
its desert most city right its northern
it's Adame edge of the Gobi on the edge
of the Taklamakan desert just north of
the guitar I'm are sorry of the Tian
Shan Mountains and you see multi-million
individuals living in this city and this
city was founded by the Tong dynasty
okay at the time of the height of the
Silk Road 7th century this is a city
that acted as part of a trade network
and while yes I would argue that this
was a network that linked civilizations
there's no questions question I would
argue that in fact I am going to show
you in fact that it's derived from a
civilization it derives from its own
source of the civilization that looks
something more like this now you might
say that's impossible
there's no cities here there's no
nothing this is just an open grassland
very much like the images you saw in the
long short and so this is we have a long
way to go between this you know the
start of our constants of
and getting here but before we delve
into that I didn't do some some I did
some shopkeeping here I you know I've
never really spent much time on the west
coast I did have a sabbatical at UCLA
but I'm from New York I grew up on the
East Coast I live in st. Louis now at
Washington Washington University I'm
just kind of hanging out with stuff you
academic types so I wasn't really sure
what to wear so I consulted but I can
only imagine as an outsider was some
sort of obscure grey literature and
found that in fact there was a guide now
you might know chuckle and I apologize
here to the to the ladies in the room I
initially took in all possibilities but
resolved on on at least male gender
attire I couldn't really find any of
these appropriate to me but I did find
one unifying characteristic everyone's
wearing pants now it's a little bit hard
for me to see so I apologize but and I
don't normally ask the cart for any
crowd participation I know it's very
it's actually a faux pas when giving
kind of a public lecture but I want by a
show of hands anyone who's wearing two
legged pants today to raise their hand
now I want everyone in the front here to
turn back and look and keep your hands
up for a second now I'm no mathematician
although I do have a degree I think it's
about 98% of you who are wearing pants
and so to allow me a mild digression as
we explore ants now it's not for nothing
that lévi-strauss was here in San
Francisco I mean it I use this as an
example and in fact these are the oldest
known pants or the oldest on jeans found
somehow I guess you can go to the
lévi-strauss museum and find these
historical pants like in there you know
factory tour or what have you they
apparently were washed up in some cave
and they were bundled and things and
they had them on display and what I love
is the is these vintage at googled
vintage Levi's advertisements and
there's some really beautiful ones if
you really want to
into it but what was coinciding with all
of them was first of all okay this is
what relates back to the techies I think
is you know the farmers mechanics and
miners I'm kind of seeing the
similarities there between techies and
farmers and my cowboys cowgirls you know
leave ice is very gala terian they
always have females and males both
riding around on horses wearing their
lovely jeans and yet this is really the
message right that Levi's and jeans and
pants are as west as you can get
it's Western as you can get my name I
see how are you going with this for
Shetty this is not a trivial point the
notion of pants as a symbol of modernity
of the west of progress and of
civilization we can go back to the 19th
century and find very serious and
important moments in historical and
historical trajectory where for example
the emperor of japan in 19th century the
meiji emperor whose goal was to
modernize japan in the eyes of the world
demanded that his courtiers the men and
the women in his court dressed in
western dress he abandoned kimonos
he banned samurai swords you've all seen
the film crews movie but this is a real
thing right and you can see it here
depicted in this fabulous wookie way
today we're not struggling with whether
civilization is represented by pants
we're struggling with whether
civilization is represented by a burqa
this is a beautiful piece of street art
in Paris I believe reflecting the Muslim
population of Paris and the
contentiousness that the burqa or the
hijab has for the concept of Western
progress and this isn't just sort of
anecdotal in fact one of my colleagues
at Washington University John Bowen has
written extensively on this topic this
is an entire book about the state and
institutional laws and rules that
underlie this strict bias and this puts
us puts our minds in a challenging
position a polarized position because we
say but I'm a FEMINIST right I mean I
could've easily worn like my shirt that
said fact my partner
has a wonderful shirt it says I'm
feminist as hell and yet we're
challenged by this idea that someone
should express their civilization in the
way that they choose it extends beyond
that as we struggle with the way in
which clothing and attire and
personality is reflected in things like
turbans and the sort of profiling that
occurs for example when we wear a turban
and we if I were to wear a turban and
grow my beard out would I be stopped at
the airport we associated with these
Taliban or Pashtuns right we have this
very cloudy sort of fuzzy boundaries
about what people wear and how it gets
translated into our notions of modernity
and again we see examples for example
the Madras army these are Sikhs I
believe who are forced to wear European
clothes to be part of the East India
Company this is where the irony comes
around where do the oldest-known pants
come from it's not England it's not
France it's not Italy but in fact the
oldest-known pants archaeologically come
from the Silk Road unsurprisingly
because when you ride horses all the
time just like the Levi's say you want
to have a comfortable pair of pants and
here you see this pristinely a preserved
horse rider in his shallow grave with
the aridity of the Taklamakan desert
here in Torf on preserving none other
than the world's oldest pants and these
date to about 3,000 years ago you can
see them today in autumn Chi ironically
enough in that in that city with the
towering expansion you can find those
pants in the museum there I'll come back
to these later in the lecture let's
first take a look at the Silk Road
because that's really why you're here
the pants are an entry point for us to
understand that the Silk Road was a
mechanism by which not only culture and
society was translated but in fact
civilization was transit
and what I want to convince you of it
it's not necessarily the translation of
East Asia to Southwest Asia or Europe to
China but in fact it was the translation
of a civilization that is open and
connected across that territory that
evolved out of out of a time scale that
was even greater than 2000 years Stewart
asked me at the beginning to clarify
exactly how many years we can sort of
count the Silk Road as an existing thing
and I said there it's like a classic
academic kind of sort of depends on you
know what you believe is the start of it
and I'm going to try to convince you
that it goes back more than 2,000 2,000
is a safe number I'm gonna convince you
that it goes back 4,000 years and as
long-term thinkers I think none of you
will have too big of a problem with that
what bothers me more about this map is
not the sort of depiction of the of the
Silk Roads as connecting cities per se
but as single roads and you'll see as I
develop through the lecture you'll note
that in fact the Silk Roads were not a
single road but were in fact thousands
if not tens of thousands of short
networks of communication and it's at
this point that we find the connectivity
with the notion of open source so what
we're really utilizing here is that is
the capacity for networks to illustrate
something about civilization rather than
the metrics of progress such as cities
agriculture irrigation you know etc we
also have to discuss a little bit about
history because of course our notions of
nomadic societies and of Central Asia
come from historical documentation
largely so here for example you see some
artifacts and then in the top of the
page you see two golden artifacts one is
a golden comb not much larger than my
hand and the other one is a golden
torque to be worn around the neck and
depicted in those golden artifacts are
Scythian nomads these are nomads of
about the first millennium BCE mid first
millennium they were a dominant
community that lived across the entirety
of the Eurasian steppe and they were met
on their southern boundaries by the
Hellenistic world and by China in the
east
um here you see the campaign's of
Alexander the Great roughly the same
time period and what's interesting about
these sort of juxtaposition of these two
artifacts is that in the golden artifact
you see a Scythian warrior wearing pants
driving his spear into this fallen Horse
depicting this sort of battle scene and
of course this is how Herodotus
describes the city it's right Herodotus
describes them as landless as knowing no
agriculture is chopping the heads off
their enemies and dangling them from the
from the left from the the bits of their
horses so much Hanan and historians of
the han dynasty refer to the Xiong nu in
the eastern nomadic communities of
Mongolia as you know the fiercest
warriors that they've ever encountered
on the lower panel you see in fact
Alexander with his lions crown attacking
Persians in this case and you see the
persians also wearing sort of pants
Alexander does not wear pants
Alexander's wearing a tunic because
pants hadn't come to Europe yet and yet
the synergy or the stateís the assume
the assimilation between the two images
on his remarkable the golden piece was
carved by Greeks as a trade tribute for
the for the for the Scythian they were
actually in quite close interaction this
notion of a boundary between the two of
them is probably overstated as shown by
trade items and the craftsmanship that
goes into these tribute items that were
paid to decisions in fact the the relief
on the bottom is from a fourth century
AD four century CE II sarcophagus
reflecting almost the exact same scene
in this case we crafted to honor
Alexander himself
so it's this historical two perspective
in a way that has cast a servant ignored
the fact that paths come from Central
Asia and pants come from the Silk Road
and all the markers that we have of
modernity and and progress in many cases
have earlier in different origins and
that's what I'm going to illustrate to
you as much as much as possible tonight
and we trade them for this historical
idea of nomadic societies as violent
barbaric landless tribal very many of
the same kind of words that we hear
thrown about for
for the barbarians of our world today
the folks that we see as other and it's
this image that has left archeologists
out of this region so when we look at
the cradles of civilization that we know
today as historians and as
archaeologists we don't think about the
middle parts of Asia we think about
these places the Aegean Egypt Sumeria
the Indus Valley in China this is just
in the old world could include of course
new world examples but what's similar
about all of these they're all urban
agricultural riverine these are the past
dependencies that carry through our
notion of civilization to this day so
what comes from this region that was
where I was 25 years ago when I first
started working in this part of the
world I didn't actually know it was held
back from us largely because of the
Soviet Union we were unable to work in
many of those Stan countries right
Kazakhstan Uzbekistan Kyrgyzstan etc and
so our notion of civilization is not
created for those places we actually
don't have a narrative and that's part
of what I'm here to bring to you tonight
and also to help then relate that to
where we are today and where we're going
so let's first talk a little bit about
that old model of civilization and I
want to problematize it so these are
some interesting images these are
satellite images of borders so the
northern in the upper panel you see
China and Kazakhstan where you see on
the right-hand side of your vision the
agricultural fields and development of
China and the left hand the natural so
to speak deserts of Kazakhstan which you
just saw in the mantra in a long short
and of course the us-mexican border
again these dynamic polarities and what
these polarities illustrate from the
concept of civilization are quite the
tendencies are quite deep and in our
vision of the world one is core and
periphery we're the center of
civilization very the periphery right
this is why you know Bach Sacha Baron
Cohen and then in the early 90s can make
a stupid movie about Kazakhstan because
who cares
they're only the seventh largest oil
producers in the world they only have
the fourth or fifth largest landmass
nobody only 15 million of them we have
that in Brooklyn now most of our
hipsters so core periphery is a really
key thing for us to challenge when we
start to think about what drives the
Silk Road is it the Chinese driving the
Silk Road or was it these peripheral
regions that maybe had more influence
globalized in local we're globalized we
speak languages I have shoes important
from Italy I'm not really I don't know I
just trying I mean I really try to do a
riche op for the techie thing but it's
it's this notion that that globalization
is available to those with power and
everybody else is the recipient of it we
can take Africa I think as a best
example of this today we see Africa
today as this kind of peripheral region
that needs our help they're engaged and
they have been engaged in globalization
for millennia I promise you and we're
actually what the publish a book with
one of my colleagues called prehistoric
globalization where we're actually
showing so many of these inroads into
Africa thousands and thousands and years
ago civilized in barbarian I've already
covered that to a certain extent this
notion that pastoralists and the
peripheries are these kinds of you know
populations without any sensibilities
and without any kind of contribution to
where we live and how we live and of
course urban rural or urban undeveloped
and these are some ideas that I want to
challenge tonight the classic examples
of these also bring up some important
concepts that bring us to sort of a
sci-fi perspective of the world today
and that is which of these two worlds is
the more utopian I recently reread Sir
Thomas More's book utopia which was part
of a side project that I'm working on on
utopia dystopia as a juxtaposition and
what I realized was that all of these
constructions the Great Wall of China in
a lot of ways you know we understand it
is you know the wall that separates the
barbarians from the Empire of China so
who creates that boundary who creates
that wall and says inside is utopia
outside is dystopia inside the walls of
work is the cosmology of the city
outside is periphery and these
boundaries are the things that again I
want to challenge with the idea of
mobility and nomadism and the way in
which these populations that didn't
construct cities and didn't for
thousands of years
participate in the very basic rudiments
of civilization that we understand
generally when I say we I mean Western
that in fact we have to kind of begin to
rethink this whole thing so one way of
rethinking it is to use this model of
open source open network or what I call
an open ecumene now ecumene is a weird
word and I've struggled with it with my
editors and with my colleagues because
it's not as a roll off the tongue right
an open source does open ecumenical a
Greek word like a minute which just
means world of known world which
actually interesting Lee comes from the
base word Aiko's which is just a hot
word for home which I'll get that I'll
get to the very end of my lecture like
the very last slide the open ecumene
though which is kind of the modernized
american version of the word like you
many because who's gonna walk around
saying we come in a is this concept that
worlds are created not as static
progressive units that go from small to
large you know small scale to large
scale organized or disorganized to
organized bands two tribes achieved in
two states but in fact that worlds are
created by this open process within
which information flows information dies
information gets animated information
gets redeployed right this is how
networks function I don't need to tell
you guys if interestingly enough this
image adapted from a woman I found on
the internet a scholar called Diane
Klein shows the very same Empire of
Alexander the Great as mapped visa vie
his historical networks I just think
it's a beautiful image and she maps it
across her work in so many different
ways and it allows us to start to
realize how permeable this notion of an
empire could actually be maybe empires
aren't these solid state controlled
hegemonies maybe in fact they're far
more permeable in mosaic than we give
them credit for or then we over over
credit them for
so this is my last sort of slide on
civilizations what I want to propose to
you tonight is to somewhat step away
from this old model of civilization
which is I think I think quite rigid
quite unsustainable in some ways
state-based markets urban satellite
settle territorial Imperial colonial
economies and hedge image emanates of
ideology and power underneath that you
see a ziggurat
so I liked how that played out on the
right you see the gear works which
reminded me above the long now clock
this is the turning wheels of scale of
multiple scales of networks and
intersections these are the places where
this is the kind of model in which
civilization is modular interoperable
and it can be scaled with different
different ranges depending on who you're
talking to this is the experiences I
have living amongst nomads of Central
Asia today is that information is
permeable and the worlds that they
create are not necessarily fixed by
national boundaries they're in fact
trans local and mobile so how does this
all get started how do we create a model
of an open ecumene we can't just imagine
it right there has to be some scientific
data to prove that this might even be
possible or at least possible in some
places now I'm not going to deny that in
Egypt they created a state they created
these incredible urban you know
civilizations fine what about these
territories we don't know what can we
say about those depicted in this image
is a Google Earth kind of
three-dimensional view looking eastward
from the desert of lake ball Kosh what
you'll notice I come back to you
numerous times I won't use the planer
too much but I want to point out here
this is Lake Bosch and this is a small
lake in southeastern Kazakhstan you'll
notice that it's kind of a half Crescent
it'll keep popping up in the images so
just you can use it as an orientation
looking from that lake towards China
we're viewing our June gar mountains
which rise to about 4000 meters of
elevation and on the foothills I've been
working for about 20 years the site of
B'gosh I'll be talking a lot about it's
a small little camp site
take you there in a minute and the
sights of Dolly and Todd's boss two
other small campsites all of which date
to about five thousand years ago this is
where we're going to be spending a
little bit of time to look at the
archaeology before we get into the
sights I want to give you a brief
orientation to the geography because the
geography and environment and ecology of
this region is fundamental to how we
understand yet the adaptiveness of these
populations you might wonder well why
don't they build cities why didn't they
pass through these stages of development
like we see for example in Mesopotamia
or the Yellow River Valley well part of
it is because it's desert and grassland
what you saw in that long short video
which was really ideal for this lecture
because it brought to life that really
extreme in and difficult environmental
scope and you see how far and how
distant those across the territory those
landscapes extent they go from the
iranian plateau all the way basically to
the forest of siberia and it's desert
and grass and desert and graphs and
mountains and desert mountains and grass
and it you don't get that many
opportunities to really settle down and
plant the soils on is good the climate
is extremely continental freezing in the
winter and boiling in the summer it's
great this is a more realistic image in
terms of the actual grass cover and what
you can see here is an interesting band
of territory running kind of on this
between the two stars the green at the
top is the Eurasian grasslands and I'm
not going to spend too much time on that
area because it's not really where the
silk road's run in fact this is one of
the big discoveries in a lot of ways is
that the silk road's mimic and run along
the grass foothills that extend along
the mountains of inner Asia and those
are the mountains that go from northern
Afghanistan into Pakistan to Kyrgyzstan
Kazakhstan and ultimately to southern
Russia over a number of different ranges
it's essentially an extension of the
Himalayas as they arc around the western
fringe of the border of China in the
area where I've been working again
keying in on that on that Crescent Lake
you can see here from a satellite image
the range of habitats you go from within
a span of only 300 kilometers you go
sand dunes the glaciers and this is a
really convenient laboratory for
understanding how human adaptation fits
in with social change because we can
actually relate the grasslands in the
deserts to this expansive environment
another way of viewing it is through
rainfall so the image here in blue is
the same territory in this case related
to the wettest quarter of rainfall
throughout the year so about you know
one quarter of the year you get the most
rain in that blue band you'll notice
that humongous
yellow zone in the middle that's mostly
desert and arid grassland so of course
when we think about the way in which
nomadic systems evolved meaning hurting
and pastoralists systems we have to
relate those back to this rainfall map
in the northern part of the Eurasian
steppe we have large bodied domestic
animals cattle and horse that take
advantage of the seasonality of that
grassland shift so in the winter time
the South becomes habitable you get a
little bit more moisture folks can move
to the south trance trance migrate to
the south in order to sort of take
advantage of those southern grasses and
in the summer when it warms up in
Siberia contracts they melt they move
right up to the fringe of the desert
fringe of the forest and those larger
bodied mammals like horses and cattle do
better so you'll notice here that the
animals are sized according to their
report importance within each one of
those regional economies in prehistory
where I work in an area which I've
called the inner asian mountain corridor
that linking territory that runs east to
west and north to south along the inner
asian mountains the adapted updation is
a little bit different here you're in
elevation systems you do have arid
systems but you also have rockier and
grassy er environments and so sheep play
a big role and I want to focus on sheep
because they'll come become important in
the latter stages of this lecture but I
also want to focus on the icon there of
the wheat grain this is also the only
territory of the northern Eurasian
region where we see the development of
farming along with mobile hurting so in
those other regions it eventually gets
there but not until roughly the first
millennium BC farming moving up this
mountain corridor is an important task
understanding the very first
connectivity that we might think of as
the Silk Road and I'm going to take you
there first we need to see however how
that mobility functions and establish in
our minds what this mobility patterns
seasonal and annual mobility looks like
for these nomadic communities the long
lines going north and south illustrate
just what I was talking about the
southern that the winter pastures in the
south the summer pastures in the north
and those vast longitudinal lines can
extend sometimes over 500 to 800
kilometers however if you look towards
the southern and eastern ranges in this
case of Kazakhstan along that mountain
corridor you see that the amount that
the pathways are shortened and those
shorter pathways are Keith what we're
going to talk about because it's a
question of frequency when you make long
drawn-out migrations you have less
frequency for contact but when you have
short migrations and they're limited by
territory like mountains you have
greater frequency of contact and it's
that exact model this idea of utilizing
rich highland pastures in juxtaposition
to comfortable winter locations in the
lowlands that creates the network and
this is how the network start to form
now this is pretty old work for me
honestly this is my dissertation work
20-some years ago
24 years ago but the ability to take
this model and apply it at a large scale
actually we couldn't do it and then in
the in the late 90s I mean maybe you had
the computing power I certainly didn't
to be able to run this model over vast
territory at high resolution and so this
network create creates this creation of
a network between mobile communities is
what we wanted and understand as a
potential for as a formative device or a
formative mechanism by which
connectivity and the ecumene start to
take form so how do we understand this
from first to an archaeological
perspective so pre modeling let's zoom
into one of this those little red dots
one of those put those sites that we
actually located the site of B'gosh is
one of the places rival work for a very
very long time and the site itself is
very small it lasted 4,000 years talk
about a long now
Janerio this is a small campsite about
the size of this flat part of the stage
here not much bigger and there's 4000
years of occupation the roman empire 900
800 years the mongol is about 300 be
gosh
little tiny site looks kind of like this
no empire there but this site sustained
for 4000 we should see the different
levels here i just want to give you a
sense of what the archeology looks like
but perhaps more important than the
excavation is this continuity and
economy here you see the the food that
they the animals that they were eating
throughout 4000 years of occupation is
basically unchangeable now it doesn't
mean if the societies didn't change they
did they change in technology they
changed in their development of contacts
etc and i'll show you some of that in a
second but the rudiment of their life
the basic way that they survived was by
moving their animals up and down
hillsides and eating sheep goat and
cattle and some riding horses in the
sight of the gosh at the site of B'gosh
in addition to all that sort of boring
archaeology collecting sticks and stones
and rocks and ceramics we found this
wonderful little preserved grave in that
grave where human remains cremated
around for 2200 BC about 4,000 some odd
years ago and in the sediments of that
soil we found the earliest known grains
for this region and those grains were of
two different kinds wheat on the one
hand and millet on the other now how
many people had millet for breakfast
anybody even had millet okay
I mean you know it's like I have like a
milot bar in my pocket right now millet
is one of the most important grains for
East Asia it was first domesticated in
China and it was the staple crop before
rice for most of these days it's the
earliest domesticated in China in
addition to be gosh we've done more work
right and we found to get another one of
these little stone boxes with yet
another burned and cremated body but yet
another round of seeds so this is a
trend it is early stage around 2500 BC
4,500 years ago people were burning
bodies and either putting seeds into
their ceremony or those seeds were
somehow with the individuals and we get
them through the flotation process and
we had these little charred grains and
we can date them and we now know that
the earliest farmers in these regions
were in fact nomads wait a minute
how can that be I once had a scholar at
Berkeley uh say to me I showed him some
ceramics and these are nomadic ceramics
he said nomads don't have ceramics I
said no they do he said no they're
nomads by definition they can't have
ceramics I'm going to show you nomadic
cities in a little bit seriously in fact
this is that argument I was making about
the grain this is the earliest quote
evidence for the Silk Road now it's not
the Silk Road of that earlier map it's
not an imperial connective network etc
this is the earliest foundations of
connectivity between East and West we
have millet and wheat to domesticate
switch start on opposite ends of Asia
for the first time and the oldest I'm
joining here OOP wrong direction there
it is here right in the middle of the
inner asian mountain corridor and that's
the territory that will become the
territory of the Silk Road so you could
argue this is the oldest evidence for
the Silk Road only in the press though
it's not just cranes by the second
planting NBC we've got a whole variety
of objects that are flowing through this
inter agent and corridor here you see
archaeological evidence for burials and
in this case burials that extend from
east to west very similar similar kinds
of syntax how do you treat a dead person
if you were to arrive in another country
and participate in a ceremony of how to
bury a dead body you need to know what's
going on how are you gonna do it right
or wrong these are communities over vast
territories that seem to have a similar
comprehension of what goes on in the
afterlife I don't call it a religion but
it could be remember these these are
interesting it because their parents but
they're also interesting because of how
they were made these art wills now I
think I'm wearing a twill I think a
houndstooth there's a twill jeans are at
will I'll show you those in a second
half you in here are probably wearing a
twill and you might say who cares well
the reason why we have to care about
twill is not only because it's a
beautiful cloth but twill is extremely
durable so the reason for making those
pants out of twill is because there were
horse riders just like the way in which
we make jeans to be durable
in fact Levi's would have made a lot
less money if they had chosen to do a
cross stitch the problem with making a
twill is that you have to separate two
of the warp warp strings from the weft
strings in order to run the to get the
diagonal pattern that gives you that
strength so that doesn't run down the
seam in fact this is what gives you that
tensile strength so you need to have a
special loom there's only a couple types
of looms that will allow you to do this
and one of them is the two beam loom how
do you find a loom in archaeology well
we find loom weights and we find some
evidence for those two beam looms this
is some work by one of our late scholar
Elizabeth Barbour who was a real expert
on textiles and the earliest evidence
for the vertical to beam loom comes out
of the Caucasus and she proposed in
order to link the early evidence for
tools with the early evidence with the
looms
that it passed across the Eurasian
steppe but now we have a much better way
of understanding how that loom might
have connected to the populations who
actually needed it most
probably through the inner Asian
mountain corridor and here I'm gonna
take you to some of the evidence again
from B'gosh now you might say how do you
find textiles from 5,000 years ago
especially you know in the desert fine
there are mummies and things but how do
you find it in these more you know well
watered Foothill grassland zones well
it's a neat little factor ceramic or
textiles are also used in the process of
molding ceramics and so we have a whole
host of ceramics that have textiles
impress right into the back of them and
we can with the help of one of my former
PhD students we can make casts of that
to get the positive and get really
high-resolution cast of what the
textiles look like and here you see one
of those casts in fact again because we
can locate those ceramics and time and
in chronology we can actually give you a
history of the textiles as they produced
through this simple nomadic campsite and
to draw it all together the site of
B'gosh here is one of the earliest known
sites in Asia to actually have evidence
for at will so again we see this broad
connectivity in the realm of pants last
case from prehistory let's look at the
way in which metals we all use metal I
mean everybody in this room is sitting
in a metallic building with metallic
cars and iron and steel and alloys and
all sorts of good stuff
how do networks of metal take shape when
was the last time you went out and dug
up a metal
I haven't actually I have
we're gonna now go to the set we're
gonna go away from B'gosh for a while
and go over here to this group of sites
get called Ellie and Tom's boss and look
at some of their metallurgical process
so at Dahle we found evidence for both
the mining the smelting as well as the
actual end products right the objects
that we know of as bronze and that's
cool
bronze is a you know it's the Bronze Age
we expect them to have bronze but what's
neat about their bronze is simply that
their bronze doesn't come from their own
minds they are the objects that they are
creating are using ores that don't come
from the local mines so they're there's
a network in a circulation of metal so
this creates a social world in which
metal is a trade object maybe being used
not as a currency perhaps but as a proto
currency or as a proto form of of a
social payment of reciprocity and if we
track out those networks using the
elements in the metal themselves of some
shared work with a colleague of mine at
Cambridge we can actually say it in the
earliest Bronze Age you have very
localized networks in the middle Bronze
Age those networks begin to join and
this is using just a basic network
software and by the Late Bronze Age you
can see the generation of those networks
through the material objects themselves
so we don't have to speculate about
whether these networks occurred we know
they occurred and we know those networks
occurred as far from Kazakhstan to India
at this time this is 2000 BC 4000 years
ago and who cares so great they were
trading in ores the Xiang Empire one of
the key Imperial forces that drives the
rise of China used as its fundamental
religious and ideological point of
control and access to royalty and elite
status bronze and where do they get
their broadest their bronze technology
it imports from the northwest from
nomadic technology this was a huge
scandal in China even as recently as two
or three years ago I mean I'm serious we
went to conference after conference
after conference to show this is how it
comes in the chronology of it the
technology the alloys the tin itself has
to be imported
so all those big bad barbarians that
we're attacking at the fringe the
Chinese needed them they needed him real
bad because the Shia Shang Dynasty
depended on bronze vessels those
beautiful things to create their ritual
economy now what is the impact if the
bronze age was the start of the Silk
Road let's say I think that we can
illustrate there was a lot of
connectivity happening if that was
happening what is the impact of it and
how do we model it so that network again
is important another way of thinking
about this is who was more important
Marco Polo or sheep now I did some
technical work but most didn't the most
difficult part of the project was
actually engine to genetically
engineering tiny sheep to put into a cup
to then do some hydrological modeling
what I decided to do I should go back a
slide because I've skipped over it
this image shows about two thousand
sheep flowing across a landscape in
Uzbekistan this is a place where we're
digging now and that flow of sheep gave
me an idea can we think of sheep like
water how did the flows of animals
across this landscape create networks or
create points of connectivity
maybe that year after year after year
that frequency of networks did something
special the technical details they're
published you can get there and we
basically took lots of variables and we
mush them together we put them in the
computer and kind of smashed it and
shook it and we end up with a simulation
it looks like this each one of these
simulation illustrates a rivulet of
sheep each year being a unique rivulet
that then forms and then you iterate
that over and over and over again
slightly changing some of the variables
creating diversity and the network's
kind of mimicking the choices that
humans make and the fact that you get in
a fight with your brother-in-law or that
the the passageway was the the pass over
the mountains was closed whatever the
choices were you create these diverse
pathways and as you iterate over and
over and over again sometimes they link
up they sort of spark and that spark can
be then accumulated for your time and
here's 500 of those iterations so
roughly 500 years
worth of slightly changing mobility
patterns and just so you can see what
this is the whole Silk Road by the way
or just about I mean this is just the
part I can show on the screen it keeps
going in the other direction here's an
even greater detail seventy-five percent
of all known Silk Road sites and
historical period map on to those
particular predicted routes so you can
basically provide the highest accurate
most accurate map of the Silk Road ever
made with seventy five percent accuracy
and that's ten to the six z-score so
we're like seventy five percent but it's
really really really good if you think
about the way that map looks it's not a
single highway east to west this is not
a Roman Road this is a dynamic open
network in which populations were
interacting and in which that flow of
information and Technology and all the
things that we come to understand as
simple and as basic as peaches and pants
and gunpowder flowed and we see the
site's right alongside it here's the
site of Tasha robot a caravanserai at
three thousand five hundred meters
that's like twelve thousand something
feet who builds a hotel if we thought a
tent at 12,000 feet except for people
who own Vale this is the owner of Vale
here not only do we have sites that we
know about that fall along this map but
we actually in a sense have a sort of
treasure map now to look at places that
we didn't expect to look at and that's
one of the most exciting parts I'm
running over time a little bit I
understand that but hopefully you'll
bear with me I'm almost there
Tasha block very famous city everyone
knows about it's like Rome Cairo touch
block
we found Tosh Pollock in 2011 using
predictive models that were exact same
variables that we used to create the so
chord map and in 2011 we went up into
the highlands of Uzbekistan the same
exact Highlands where you saw those
flows of sheep you were actually looking
at the city of Peshawar and I want to
show it to you here there it is you see
it kind of right in here all of this is
the city now you might say this is the
not the kind of city I'm used to seeing
here we go
the preliminary work have shown that
this site was occupied eleven twelve
centuries on top on the surface and
these are like current period walls
thousand years old
why build a large occupation at 2,100
meters elevation why did they live here
how did they live here and for what you
know what was the river what was the
motivation as of 2015 this is our third
year working at dr. Locke
let me first discovered the site myself
and Farhad Matsuda than a team of
archaeologists from the Institute of
archeology in Uzbekistan as well as
Washington University in st. Louis what
we thought was here was just a number of
small habitations subsequent research in
2012 and 2013 revealed that this was a
much larger place this is a medieval
town or city and a large cemetery
associated to the construction you know
that they understand at least ed of this
area of course we have to do archaeology
it should be a very multidisciplinary
project the whole goal this year was to
come out with a larger team specialists
and to examine some of the specialized
parts of the city as well as the
environmental impact that a city this
large would have had on a very
precarious environment high in the
mountains here in Uzbekistan I wish I
could spend the entire hour just talking
about touch block it's an amazing
location itself it's at 2,100 meters
elevation just by comparison
that's Machu Picchu the same elevation
as Machu Picchu in fact it's almost the
same size as Machu Picchu it just
doesn't have as beautiful the llamas
aren't anywhere near as big what you're
looking at here is an animation of
ground-penetrating radar
we've only excavated a very small part
of the city so far yeah we understand
exactly how big it is where the walls
are and how its laid out simply on the
basis or using a radar signal fired into
the ground that bounces back anomalies
and gives us a very accurate map of what
is going on under the surface this is
work done by one of my most stellar
colleagues and recent PhD are about to
finish his PhD at Henry also at
Washington University and what you're
seeing here again is the emergence of
the wall this is the Citadel Mound
here's a palace on top of the Citadel
and the rest of the city they make this
a little bit clearer for you here you
can see again kind of the oh and then
running down the middle of the site is a
drainage stream this city can be kind of
understood in this fashion
you got a citadel on top with the palace
structure you've got some workshops but
it's not what we think it's a gatehouse
and gate western town and sort of a
territory out here which is sort of
beyond the main cost here at the town
itself this is about seven hectares
so hectare is about the size of a
football field so that's about the size
we're talking about and you might say
well it's kind of small it's just a town
right well this place has a cemetery
which you know illustrated here that the
graves don't show up in the radar they
only show up in magnetometry
methodological detail but what you can
see here are these little rows of dots
and each one of those dots is a human
burial and there's over 400 of them so
we have 400 buried bodies in a town the
size of like I don't even know what the
best analogy is Oakland not even like
downtown I don't know
Union Square I'm not sure I shouldn't
have even attempted
I'm from the East Coast now I really
know it's a director what to wear um so
you might say well ok who are these
CARICOM names why do we how does this
relate right so you found the city along
the Silk Road probably to another Silk
Road city we know about Silk Road cities
75% of them all on the Silk Road we got
it
well this one is unique or amongst the
unique sites we know of because it
belonged to a time period when the Silk
Road was controlled by the largest
nomadic Empire before the Mongols the
car accounted huh Nate this was a
company this was an aggregate of tribal
communities of nomads that decided they
were tired of having to fight against
everybody else so they got together and
created a polity and that polity had
some pretty amazing consequences first
and foremost they became not only the
traders of but the purveyors of
high-carbon steel now high carbon steel
is significant because it gives us all
the buildings in San Francisco it gives
us cars it gives us samurai swords it
gives us basically arms and when you're
in a world in which swords and
battle-axes are your number one arms
having a sword that's a lot better than
a piece of of crap casted iron is really
important how important important enough
that the Arab armies of the Caliphate in
the near east purchased their swords
from Central Asia and no swords became
the very swords that deflected the first
Crusaders and won the first crusade for
the Arab armies high carbon steel has
never been unimportant from the day it
was invented until now that economic
drive also inspired them to start to
participate participate in notions of
civilization that could in fact be seen
as exterior to their nomadic origins
they hired Persian architects and worked
with local developers to make maza Leia
and incorrect and some of them are quite
incredible these are standing Mozilla
from the attenti century probably built
though by technicians and architects
that were part of an imperial structure
as opposed
to those sort of strictly nomadic
communities living in the mountains they
had poets cartographers polymaths
astronomers this map on the right is by
Mahmoud Kashgari which illustrates the
world as it was known the ecumene right
and here you might say if it doesn't
look much like a world map but very much
like the long now clock we'll look in
ten thousand years I promise you it is
this is a map that shows lakes and
rivers in and the Caspian Sea in India
and other places it's actually all
labelled up in that these are not folks
who were barbaric outsiders but in fact
at this stage in their development were
beginning to assimilate to a broader
civiles model of civilization one that
extended at the height of the Silk Road
we have evidence for it we have it in
the artifacts that we find at OSH block
we have for example mirrors from the
cell jokes and coinage stamped with
their own rulers we know these were
their coins we have inscribed cups and
bowls in this case with Arabic writing
and we have objects like this at our at
our site in tasha block high in the
mountains we also know what they were
eating pretty well look this is just the
list some work done by my former PhD
student Rob Spangler who's now in
Germany the list of all the goodies they
were eating in the palace peaches and
melons and grapes stuff wasn't growing
at 12,000 feet I promise you they were
importing it and they were up there and
they were making money selling steel and
they were trading and they were
operating that high mountain Silk Road
just like that fluctuating map right
just as an aside I had been doing some
archival research for this whole thing
on fruit trade and I found this
wonderful series of photographs at the
Library of Congress and you can there
recolor it right so they're
black-and-white images that they use
this technology to put the color back
into and this is a really amazing one of
the Oh could bring the lights down for
just two seconds is to see the look on
that man's face if it shows up all right
now that's the man in 1913 who sells
grapes and berries and and such and this
is my photo in 2003 and I'm pretty sure
that's the same guy
now Tosh Bulaq itself is a fascinating
place and we're gonna continue to work
there with your money so please please
let us know when you're ready it's like
a wedding I have one of those big in
Italian wedding you like one of those
big baskets and you just put the money
in it just kidding
I want you to come and participate in an
intellectual way because this city's an
important lesson for us - block did grow
up pretty fast but it only lasted 200
years and I think it was the hubris of
the carrot onions they were known a
nomadic polity they were doing just fine
for hundreds of years prior to that
conglomerate political unity they
started to compete with empires they
started to build cities and settle down
and dive into that old model of
civilization and I think it was their
downfall I think they went too far I
think that they stopped being
sustainable they stopped having the kind
of connectivity that occurred now the
Mongols had something to do with it but
the Mongols ironically deposed them so
they were too rigid too stable to
assimilative if you will
now I'm not fighting against
assimilation but I'm fighting against is
the idea here that this nomadic system
which had functioned for already 2,000
or more or 3,000 years this connectivity
and network and it's open ecumene
started to lock up and the continents in
the sense played a role in that and
their networks froze and their cities
died so we're coming to the end where
Eurasian nomads the first futurists were
they the first communities to actually
realize that sustainability and
innovation can go hand in hand provided
we balance it with environment and
connectivity does power have to be rigid
does power have to be locked up in urban
structures and bureaucracies or can it
be more open source can it be something
that in fact moves and is adaptive and
is interoperable and multiscale today
we're confronted with
urban ISM population growth disease and
progress at get catastrophic levels
you've all seen Al Gore's pitch I don't
need to convince anyone in this room I
hope that what we're doing is not
sustainable
even in our best technological way this
is the city of Molly on the beautiful
tourist islands of the Maldives where I
just started a new project looking at
the collapse of the Silk Road this is
the most dense per capita per land area
urban center in the world I believe are
one of them just offshore is the
beautiful island of Phillip Uschi this
is where all the garbage from all that
goes and it's just on fire all the time
now when there's storm waters or surges
what do you think all that goes visit
the Maldives we don't need to laugh land
will build Islands
well dredge up the ocean will bleach out
the coral it's not an ecological system
right right yet and this is really where
we put the part of the finer point on
our perspective of civilization this is
our model of SpaceX now I'm a huge fan
of a lot of the projects that come out
of Tesla and out of SpaceX in the sense
that I think that they've popularized
and made cool the idea of sustainable
energy I think there's a lot of projects
there that are amazing this one gives me
pause because as a individual who's for
the last 25 years studied sustainable
systems of know of mobile nomadic
communities and there are nonetheless
important influence on civilization this
model of growth on a planet which isn't
built for us makes me stop and wonder it
makes me wonder whether urbanization is
in fact everything we need
they makes me wonder whether the kinds
of progress that we see it as being
fundamental to our civilization is in
fact the only way and given the world or
it is today I leave that to the long now
and
one here to help figure out but this is
my parting image I was in Indonesia on
the island of Lombok this past Christmas
and I spent that Christmas or that new
year in a village called goun goun sorry
Azusa totally and that village had this
young girl living in it and every day we
would walk up this hill to our little
bungalow which we rented on Airbnb and
this young girl would be collecting clay
from back yard and what she was making
were little models of her ideal world
and here you see her house it's two
stories with a little shelter on top you
got some babies you got the family and
we said what is this you see this is my
future her future it is is something
that's very sustainable very realistic
very rooted in the very and in the exact
things that I think challenged us as
highly developed highly computerized
highly progressive societies now I'm not
expecting anyone here to go move to a
village in Indonesia it would probably
ruin it but we do need to understand
that there are reversals so that utopian
vision that we have to our world
there's dystopia as well and when I left
this village this seemed like a utopia
thank you
there you go
Pepsi
questioning that Kevin put on top as you
mentioned water very much how does that
fit in all this I am some here absent
yeah in terms of like the day-to-day
life of prims water or the overarching
kind of framework of water yeah the
day-to-day and sort of where the folks
are and where they're not yeah um so
these pastoralists systems of course all
human habitations and adaptations that
rely on having you know drinkable water
both in themselves and their animals and
what's unique about the Eurasian steps
and especially these mountains owns is
in fact they're very well watered they
get up to a thousand millimeters of
rainfall at elevation when you go down
in elevation you can range from these
really really dry deserts up to you know
basically well-fed ring-ring sided
foothills so it's a question of
understanding the nuanced mosaic and the
niches that are created within the scope
of these environments and in some of the
most desolate environments whether it's
the Sahara or the open deserts of
Central Asia or are lots of other
regions folks who live there and we know
that eco ecology can figure out how to
find drink you know drinkable water at a
certain scale there's not enough water
probably to sustain major cities and
that's something one of the big
difference between major hydro hydraulic
oils hydraulic systems like the Yellow
River but so you know Tigris and
Euphrates and Nile those river systems
allowed for that kind of expansive
growth here you have smaller rivers
you've got a kind of a very different
set of hydraulic conditions that in a
way stilted that otherwise that's a
alternative model or the main model that
we know and it kind of led way for this
alternative way so later when the
caravans are coming along these sheep
Forge pathways they're finding water
enough to not have to carry a lot of
water well that's why that I think the
tracks are following through the
foothills because there's plenty of
water in the foothills it's really when
you get out into the plains that it gets
to be pretty sketchy so then you get out
for the desert plains and then you've
got to make a beeline between water
source to water source which there are
but it's much easier to pass through the
elsewhere you're getting especially in
the summer in the wintertime you know I
would I imagine the travel along the
Silk Road in the wintertime was pretty
was fairly limited I mean it's always
occasional use of these pathways
mm-hmm I would say you know if you just
take an environmental perspective the
high passes open up around May to June
so you only have a few months in the
high passes again you need navigators
and so who are the folks that best know
the mountains it's part of the logic
behind the model in and of itself you
know if you were gonna go wander across
the Rocky Mountains you'd try to find
yourself find yourself a mountain person
to take you over the mountains these
mountain folks have been living there
for 4,000 years
they know the ways through the mountains
so that's your guide that's part of
their no I think it's more of a
participatory arena I think that the
notion that yeah you don't have caravans
that like leave Xian and end up in
Jerusalem these are objects and items
and packages that are being passed along
and every time you cross into a
territory we actually have historical
records of this going back you know
quite far into into the into the written
record where caravans would come into a
new valley or a new pass and they'd be
met by horse riders or by individuals
you know nomadic individuals who would
say this is the land of you know Stewart
calm and he wants tribute I mean you
wouldn't believe what I had to pay to
get here so this tribute this tribute
would be paid to those rulers and that
would come in the form of commodities
they've come in from trade objects
etcetera so the caravanners would plan
within their within their sort of
packaging say okay we're gonna lose 20%
along the way that's terms of tribute to
the passage etc and that would be what
some of the ways in which these objects
would flow in different direction the
heart of the caravan Suri's work
what was that system caravan trees are
an incredibly fascinating architectural
reality they're basically hotels for
caravanners right mmm
- you have spaces with the animals to be
watered they're usually at very rich or
you know well watered environments where
you have a good resting spot they're
also social networks right I mean
there's a wonderful piece of research by
one of my young scholar named Kate
Franklin who was at the University of
Chicago and she studies caravans are
around this
and her work has Illustrated that the
caravans themselves were kind of
generating this like notion of what it
was to be cultured if you will so they
created cosmologies of what you needed
to have if you were moving along the
Silk Road so I think that these caravans
her eyes functioned as much as
functional hotels and stopping points as
much as well as real conveyors of the
notion of connectivity in the notion of
culture that was occupied at of the
populations that lived there how many
different cultures are intersecting in
these places three local ones or I mean
I don't know that I can't really
necessarily answer that I mean I think
it depends on where you are you know
what segments of the Silk Road it's such
a diversified network I think there were
areas that were much more homogenized in
the sense that there are strong you know
boundaries of leadership etc but the key
is that you know these were multilingual
multi-religious I mean think about just
religions alone at least three or four
major religions were func we're flowing
across the Silk Road at any given time
you have Buddhism Islam Islam
Christianity and Zoroastrianism I'm sure
I'm missing all the Hinduism so these
are all five minimum world religions
that's I mentioned shamaness and Sufis
and other sects and populations that
were within those religions so you know
that's just one source of diversity so
you have language and religion and
ethnicity and all these things and if we
look at these populations genetically
central asians i mean from the modern
genome these are some of the most
admixed populations on the planet so
from a genetic perspective as well you
get this you know in the modern and the
modern population one of the most
admixed communities from a genetic
perspective so it makes sense that this
format of interaction this open kind of
system was moving around a lot of things
so this some of the stuff that's flowing
is really valuable and it's the Silk
Road because because something that you
had worth transporting a long distance
and high carbon steel and things like
that
wherever there's value there's usually
theft of the Deaf way of you know
there's this writings about this that
the Chinese of course love to portray
the the treachery of their trade
partnerships you know my sense that my
sense of the of that side of it is you
know it's really we're talking most
piracy in the sense right I mean to the
extent that commodities are open it's
really about who you know rather than
what
you know so if you have networks that
are secure you might actually shadow
guys to only have a short segment so you
would bring your your wares only a short
segment across those social networks
that you know of this is something that
also function for example in the
Mediterranean Sea traders would go
between ports where they have your
specific oftentimes family kin or you
know for example the Berbers they had
these wonderful trade networks that
would allow for trust within the trade
system I think the Silk Road functioned
very much in the same way but you know
unlike some of the trade networks say in
historical periods in Europe we don't
have as many clear documents I mean one
of the best books on this topic is why a
woman named Valerie last name anyway I
apologize Khem Kelly has a specific
question you have all this touch block
amazing discovery and he was wondering
if there was any memory in the locals
there above any of that story or were
they just astounded to find an ancient
city in their field yeah I mean the past
couple of interesting modern aspects to
touch the luck one is it's actually a
military zone so no one has lived there
since at least the start of the Soviet
era except for nomads who can rent from
the state plots or areas of pasture so
you'll get nomadic communities living up
there and kind of putting up their tents
in the summer it's also high elevation
so it's only open for a couple of months
of summer otherwise it's buried in snow
the nomads today who operate up there
they call it the hollow hollow hill
because when you stomp on the Citadel it
kind of rings because it's mostly just
rocks and so he you know it it kind of
feels like there's something weird but
when we started to sort of open it up as
an archaeological site they had no idea
that this was something that was there
but again they're pretty busy so you
know they're like huh interesting
I know I tried to get him to dig for
free but they don't want to do I got a
couple questions on nomads one of them
from Nick is is there any evidence of
nomadic people making chairs chairs
chairs oh absolutely I have to say more
oh yeah absolutely I mean they make
saddles too right so their saddles
actually oftentimes have stands you
oftentimes see for example images of
like you know Mongolian rulers and
things sort of sitting in these stools
they're not chairs in the same exact
sense that we think of them as like
throwing chairs and that kind of thing
but I mean in a lot of ways you know
their contact with so many other
communities both Persians and and
Chinese definitely had them at least
having things that you know furniture
furniture is definitely not something
that was foreign to them but I will
there's an interesting point to be made
about chairs if you look at the relief
in Persepolis which is the first
millennium BC capital of the a commanded
Empire which is a Persian Empire they
had this beautiful panel large-scale
panel on the wall carved in stone and it
shows all of the attendances all the
attendees to sort of a procession to the
king of the echo minutes and so the king
is sitting there and he's in a throne
and everybody else is standing and the
Sith ian's the Sokka in this case but
their citizens basically they're
standing and they have their horses but
none of them are ever sitting so there
is this sort of association with a
seated posture as being one of powering
and in royalty which I don't see so
often usually they're mounted the images
of sittings Stephen Howard has kind of
complicated say the question is about
the open that can mean in nomads
wondering how this is playing out in the
present in your future as we're getting
denser and denser basically living
situations for most of humanity you know
are we nomadic any since like this now
what's the future of nomads now the
nomads you've been talking about so far
are herders yeah yeah animals yeah and
they're going up and down with the
seasons and that's a a very specific
form or no matter there's lots of the
people that travel sure so I have an
interesting analogy for this and I
apologize that this may if this may be
anachronistic or something so one of my
interesting sort of observations all
right
to me anyway oh my sort of moments of so
aha was when I realized that you're
looking at a nomadic herd and you do the
calculation and let's say there's a
herdsmen or hurting family and they've
got three thousand sheep and each sheep
is worth actually more but let's just
say for argument's sake a hundred
dollars every year they return on that
what is that three hundred thousand
three million you guys are the math
people it's a lot of money and it
returns at about twenty percent and this
is a stock mm-hm
right so they have animal stock that
stock is what allows them to kind of
have this flexibility there you know
what I don't need to pay taxes I'm gonna
move my animals and go okay here's going
back to your question about the modern
nomads
today digital nomads and communities for
whom earning your money isn't
necessarily linked to exactly where you
live mmm-hmm is it stock is it the
ability to sort of navigate networks and
earn money through remote and mobile
systems I think they're not that
different the difference of course lies
a little less seasonal little less
seasoned oh who knows people who do go
on vacation from like November till
January um but there is a point of
difference that's significant and that
is kinship so these systems there's no
you know traditional nomadic systems a
nomadic pastoralists what allows them
that security and risk reduction is
kinship so if you lose your herds in a
snowstorm or if you get a big disease
your family will bail you out now that
happens here in Silicon Valley a
paranoid state too but in a different
way
I'm talking about systemic kinship that
actually enables for systems to grow and
I think that today you know the movement
towards mobile networks and mobile
nomads that kind of thing and the whole
digital nomad environment is one that
really demands a reformation of social
networks and so we need to kind of find
social kinships that facilitate that
kind of mobility such that we're not
just you know it's not just a
dog-eat-dog world that's maybe my vision
of it but again I live in a slightly
different
so you mentioned that there was this
period kind of a Golden Age of the as
part of the Silk Road where the tribes
kind of got together stop fighting and
collaborated what do you think that was
going on there you know obvious a couple
of things so I didn't mention about the
Caracara it's another key point about
that to Confederacy is that that was
also the time when there's a rise in
very important empires out on their
fringes Song Dynasty in China as well as
the Arabic caliphate the first abbasid
caliphate both so these these two groups
were putting enormous pressure and never
there were emissaries we have historical
documents for example from the Keith on
sort of the polity in the north for the
song who would send emissaries into the
the Turkic nomadic region and say we
want to participate we want to you know
we want to trade with you guys and these
emissaries made it made their way all
the way down to the to the fringes of
Iran where you had Islamic the fringes
of the of the Abbasid Caliphate and they
said they would respond by thinking oh
you're infidels so we're not going to
trade with you mm-hmm
so the cons did something very
interesting no I can't say that what
their motivations were but in the heart
of the center part of the middle part of
the 10th century they as a state
decision convert to Islam and there that
conversion opens up and changes the face
of the Silk Road for a very long period
of time
so they're systematically participating
in currents of ideology currents of
trade etc and of course aspects in parts
of western China were part of their
therapy so it wasn't just the modern-day
border of China and so the Song Dynasty
was quite small and the continents in
fact enveloped an enormous part of what
is essentially western China and that
participation in these broader networks
I think is what fundamentally allowed
them to sort of compete with and
participate with what were essentially
Imperial forces on on all their fringes
and so it almost seems like a certain
degree of pressure then took them from
maybe was a more disarticulated open
ecumene model into something that was
more of us or axial model of real
Imperial
like an imperial kind of boundedness the
question from Shane Beverly didn't talk
about these various Imperial states and
so on and in very urbanized and
organized empires many of which failed
at various points yeah but you've also
pointed out that at various points the
there was a hiatus and traffic along the
Silk Road in a sense it failed at
various points what was that about
well so this is actually a big major
question of my current research might
your answers I don't know and I don't
know that we necessarily know the
argument that I've heard and one of them
some of them that I've read about is
that there's a sort of competitive rise
in the sixteenth century of maritime
trade and other kinds of things but
knowing what I know about the
archaeology of Central Asia and the
durability of these systems it's even in
light of sort of the Mongolian kind of
transformation and everything else it
strikes me that this system the Silk
Road should have been much more adaptive
and much more resilient no it was really
was resilient for roughly 4,000 years
even even three thousand or 2,000 that's
still pretty impressive and so that
resiliency had to go through some
fundamental change and yeah I mean it's
interesting to see that something about
that that network begins to break down I
think it must have something to do
though with the rigidity of boundaries
because the Silk Road functioned
wholeheartedly as an open system and
then I think that was really its key so
something in the historical period
whether it was a rise of timber and the
timber road state something going on
with China and you also have this is
also but you know well into the the post
tongue and other phases I mean you have
lots of dynastic developments throughout
East Asia and South Asia that I think
really constrict the flows that
otherwise enabled the Silk Road and its
predecessor and it's sort of precursor
for thousands of years so is it the fact
that we learn how to sail around around
the Horn of Africa or is it something
internal it's actually a question I'm
still asking a couple questions about
sort of your practice out there Liz
Buller asks what prompted and sustains
your interest from 20 years ago in
Central Asia and thematic networks and
another question with other names is how
are you greeted by the local population
this work they feel you'd be a boon
their culture put them back in his
really interesting what you're doing
sure um Mike you know my initial foray
into Central Asia was really
opportunistic both in sort of positive
and in somewhat sort of tragic ways you
know I'm a sort of child of the 90s or
the 80s and 90s and so I was in college
in the early 90s when the Berlin Wall
fell and you know 96 all of a sudden
there was no Soviet Union anymore thing
yeah and so like a lot so many people I
was fascinated by this region at me just
not knowing about yeah this is this big
gap in our world and I was 22 and pretty
dumb and I'm still dumb but I'm still 22
anymore and I just wanted to go to that
part of the world and I had an
opportunity to do research I started my
work in Africa so I was working with no
matter of neurologists yeah I was
already I got into an undergrad by a
really wonderful professor who kind of
stimulated me into the field I was an
engineering student actually I did my
undergraduate all knows yeah I used a
lot of the engineering in the end as an
archaeological and archaeologist but he
got me into the sort of this social
thinking and yeah one thing led to the
next and I was able to sort of enter
into Kazakhstan at a time you know 99
1998 when nobody nobody was there 99 and
then the tragic side of it actually was
9/11 so you know 9/11
two years later happens and all of a
sudden everyone wants to know what's
going on in Central Asia and what's
going on with nomads and what's
Afghanistan what are these places and
here I was about to finish my PhD as an
individual who would lived in Central
Asia for three years spoke some of the
languages all of a sudden I was like no
and you know that was for the
opportunistic the people in Central Asia
themselves are amazing it's only very
very closest friends are in fact kha'zix
news backs that gentleman you saw in the
video Farhad I mean like a brother to me
you know working out for 20 years you
realized that we've got a really sort of
limited we I mean myself included
everyone has a very limited way of
understanding the world I think it's one
of the beauty beauties about this
community and about the long now group I
mean so interested in having a wider
perspective on what the world is about
these folks are the same yeah they
want their kids to go to college and
they want all the kinds of things
they're coming out of a tough
post-soviet environment but which is now
already 30 years ago I mean it's not
like they can you know this is a whole
generation ago they still hurting
absolutely really we were just talking
about Jason code yeah I mean the the
baseline practices are still very
similar I mean you know the site is
B'gosh less than a kilometer away is a
small moderate is a contemporary hurting
village I mean they're living in the
exact same places the people are very
interested in what we're doing there's
local archaeologists you know the Soviet
tradition of archaeology was in place
and we have gotten we've got great
collaborators the Kazakh government is
extremely supportive
I've given lectures at the Embassy and
done sort of you know galas all sorts of
things for the Kazakh political side of
things as well I think it's important
because we're really now in a sense I'm
a I'm a voice one of the voices for an
asset for a heritage that isn't my own
right so if I'm going to speak for
another population and in a sense
promote them
I should clearly be interacting with
them and also including them in that
process and so we were very very
interactive in terms of how we publish
and how we work and all of our artifacts
and everything stays in country and we
work very closely with the national
governments to make sure that there's a
local museum was coming up around always
I mean they've had museums since the
Soviet era so I mean their museum their
museum structure is very well developed
in some cases even more organized than
what we have here so you know at the
state level so yeah I mean they've got
it all sorted out they don't need us per
se but what happened in the 90s and in
the early 2000s was just this kind of
fascination with different methods and
different ways of thinking and it's
really produced a very productive
collaboration so like a lot of people
here are wondering what's involved in
becoming a tourist in this area again
you can you hike and ride you can is it
easy to get there and welcome to their
places to stay oh absolutely
Kazakhstan and Kyrgyzstan in particular
are extremely easy therapies of free
they've got modern airports they fly out
to Europe multiple every other day you
can get a flight from London Germany
I'm stirred in Paris whatever I'm very
easy to get to and the people are just
amazing you know one of the key trends
in Central Asian culture is hospitality
I've been fed by families you know who
you know for camping and didn't have
anything with them or what have you and
I'm hiking through the mountains and
they bring you into their house you may
or may not be able to speak their
language they sit you down and whatever
they they have it's on the table I mean
imagine walking down the street and
having some foreigner kind of pass us by
and just because you say come on into my
house I'm gonna feed you how many people
have done that serious like we never do
that and that's sad right I mean like
this is a world in which I've been
invited into people's home so much that
they end up being lifelong friends and
these are folks who are herders and you
know whatever it's it's an amazing
culture and and as tourists you can
access that quite easily other countries
have slightly stricter visa laws but for
the most part you're not gonna find a
lot of danger or a lot of risk in those
places as I see it so what's the
landscape like this is you know so
mountainous a so steps and it's a lot
like here you know you have it's less
it's less it's less lush in terms of the
the forested areas they don't have such
large areas of forest but the mountain
areas are gorgeous like a very high
peaks the Tian Shan Mountains go up to
7,000 meters so really world-class
climbing and skiing they've got downhill
skiing in Kazakhstan it's a modern
country
it's absolutely modernized in spite of
having vast open territory it's 15
million people for a country that's
two-thirds the size of this graph United
States so that's a very low population
desert was it practical for some maniac
to besides they wanted to hike the they
wanted to do the Silk Road 4,700 miles
which direction should they go and is it
even plausible well if you believe in my
map it's absolutely impossible because
it's all over the place
no but if you look at a general arc
right and you wanted to go city to city
like all the big you know the kind of
the old way we understood the Silk Road
is these kind of big city stops the main
urban oasis cities mhm
um I would say start in Uzbekistan you
know whose becca stan gives you the
initial Flair of you know it's a bit
more exotic it's all it's all the things
that you're gonna hope for Kazakhstan is
a modern country you get to all Monty
which is essentially a medieval city
and it looks like you know any major
modern metropolis if they kind of get
off the beaten track to see some of the
monuments who's becca stan has the blue
domes and the tile and a lot of that
kind of you know really iconic and of
course that's staged a lot of us we've
rebuilt by unesco and a lot of its it's
built up as a as part of the heritage of
the sopra which direction you go I
wouldn't so the way I did it
so I've hiked most of it not hiked the
whole thing but you know donkey hike car
and dragged behind a different we
started I started I did two tracks I
started an almighty and went over the
Caribbeans on foot and then down into
China into cash car then around the
southern desert which is just an amazing
panorama if I have read the opportunity
just to do a photo lecture it's just one
of the most stunning places on the
planet and you just cross over this
whole zone Western China's a bit tougher
now China's become much more restricted
in terms of passage this was in the
early 2000 so it was trying they're
celebrating the Silk Road oh yeah I mean
right now so China has this program
right now which i think is really
important for us to understand from a
modern perspective but also a historical
one they've drawn on the Silk Road as a
model to develop a multitrillion-dollar
program called one belt one way and one
belt one way is GE things like big
pioneer project now to connect China to
the West visa via the Eurasian steppe
and their planners gonna pay for that
China's paying for it they're paving
roads in Tajikistan they're they're
helping with development in Kazakhstan
you know they've just built this huge
connect connection point in hard gose
which is a city on the border between
China and Kazakhstan where the tracks
you know because the Chinese have
different rules than the Kazakh so they
have a up offload all the stuff I mean
it's a very very high-tech modern image
and of the Silk Road and it's literally
using the historical model of this
Imperial connectivity of the Silk Road
to justify and layout the one belt one
right one way mishit 'iv now on the one
hand you might say great more global
markets it helps everybody why not use
that that trope and that's okay I'm not
an economist I'm not necessarily here to
condemn that that program but it is
important to recognize that that's not
how the Silk Road actually function it
wasn't one belt one road it was
thousands of belts and thousands of
roads with this localized
you know systemic these localized
systemics and if we lock it in and we
border it and we bound it bureaucratize
it I don't think it's gonna function the
way it did in antiquity and maybe that's
just again my sort of reticence to buy
and wholeheartedly to a very specific
form of civilization Central Asia offers
us a different model when we carve
underground and I think it bears the
kind of pay attention to that it's a
long great strange story of soldier this
is wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]